2030 un albero è stato piantato su marte
e spero che sia un videogioco 2010 30
milioni di persone piantano alberi
online su farmville virtualmente
s'intende 2020
mi chiedo perché piantare un albero su
marte quando ne abbiamo un gran bisogno
sulla terra il futuro lo costruiamo
adesso e come diceva un vecchio saggio
il miglior momento per piantare un
albero era 20 anni fa
il secondo miglior momento è adesso ho
iniziato a sporcarmi le mani quando
avevo 14 anni facendo il gelato a
partire da quella esperienza ne ho fatte
tantissime più di quaranta tra italia
danimarca e spagna e ho fatto di tutto
partendo dal mago e mi divertivo a
sorprendere i bambini farli sorridere
giocare dopo questa esperienza ho fatto
il cuoco ho fatto il cameriere o venduto
quasi di tutto porta a porta fino a
quando mi sono trovato a lavorare in
porto e ha quindi a iniziare a
commercializzare e poi alla fine ho
deciso di voler provare un lavoro serio
e quando pensiamo al lavoro serio si
pensa a lavorare in banca e un giorno ho
ricevuto un'offerta per lavorare in
banca a barcellona
se l'idea inizialmente di un lavoro
serio mi entusiasmava e mi sentivo
grande
in realtà la routine era totalmente
diversa i giorni passavano tutti uguali
e dopo circa un anno
già mi annoiavo mortalmente volevo
provare una nuova esperienza
e così sono saltato a bordo di un
progetto che voleva portare sviluppo in
africa
in realtà il progetto era interessante
aveva tutte le premesse è
sostanzialmente si occupava di portare
energia in villaggi e paesi isolati in
mezzo alla foresta del camerun
ma se il progetto aveva tutte le
prerogative bellissime quando ci siamo
trovati a lavorare sul campo
ci siamo resi conto che la realtà era
molto differente da
l'avevamo immaginata e prima di tutto
c'era un problema gravissimo legato alla
deforestazione
la maggior parte dei villaggi con cui
parlavamo svendeva ettari di foresta a
circa 1.000 dollari l'uno e subito ci
siamo detti
dovremmo provare a invertire questa
tendenza la seconda questione che ci
siamo trovati ad affrontare era legata
al i beni primari di cui avevano bisogno
forse non c'era tanto bisogno di energia
quanto per esempio di sicurezza
alimentare e così abbiamo pensato di
creare un progetto che cercasse di
risolvere queste due problematiche che
avevamo trovato sul campo era il 2010 in
toscana il 2010 è stata una grande
annata per il vino i vignaioli erano
contentissimi
anche se la primavera è arrivata un po
in ritardo e poi c'è stata un'estate
molto torrida che qualche problema lo ha
creato in quel periodo di ambiente si
occupavano principalmente i vignaioli
gli agricoltori anche se qualche
scienziato iniziava a parlare di
ambiente e del problema legato ai
cambiamenti climatici
per la verità non venivano molto
ascoltati dai media che non parlavano di
ambiente se ci pensate
greta tombeur aveva solo 7 anni e
leonardo di caprio ero impegnato a
girare film shutter island qualche media
si era occupato da ambiente in
particolare al gore aveva pubblicato un
famoso cortometraggio che si chiamava la
scomoda verità all'inizio ebbe tanto
scalpore ma poi l'interesse svanì piano
piano tanto interesse invece in quel
periodo ci fu per la conferenza del
clima a copenaghen e famose coop
io ero lì e sinceramente vi di un grande
entusiasmo un fermento un interesse
sempre nascente verso il settore
dell'ambiente questo mi entusiasmo
perché in quel periodo i media c'erano
tutto il mondo guardava a quell'evento
come un momento in cui bisognava
prendere delle decisioni e io non avevo
molto tempo e voglia di prendere
decisioni in quel periodo
ero molto impegnato su farmville il
famoso social network dove si
costruiscono fattorie virtuali ed ero
anche innamorato di una ragazza con la
quale giocavo su farmville per avere la
fattoria migliore lo facevo a volte con
qualche stratagemma perché in realtà a
belliveau la mia fattoria piantando
alberi special edition e pagandoli con
la mia carta di credito
il mio collega mi prendeva in giro
diceva sei veramente sciocco che sprechi
tuoi soldi per piantare alberi virtuali
su facebook e non raggiungerà in sé
anche il tuo obiettivo perché come
potrai conquistare una ragazza solo
perché hai la fattoria più bella su
farmville ma se in quel momento tanti
milioni di persone giocavano su farvi le
pagavano per piantare alberi virtuali
io il mio collega ci siamo detti perché
non piantare alberi veri troveremo
utenti disposti a farlo
e in quel momento abbiamo anche
ricollegato un po i puntini con la
nostra esperienza in camerun dove
avevamo visto la deforestazione e la
necessità del supportare delle
popolazioni locali e quindi unendo i
puntini ambiente e digitale abbiamo
pensato di creare un progetto che
cercasse di risolvere queste
problematiche
così ho deciso di dedicare la mia vita a
piantare alberi ma non da solo come un
eremita cercando invece di coinvolgere
migliaia e migliaia di persone online
piantare un albero è un gesto naturale e
fin da quando siamo bambini ci insegnano
che è una cosa positiva per il pianeta
a me me l'ha insegnato mio padre a
cinque anni mi ha consegnato un seme di
susino e io l'ho piantato mi divertivo a
vederlo crescere ogni giorno
e ancora oggi ogni tanto posso trovare
il mio albero quando ho iniziato le
persone mi dicevano siete sicuri di
riuscire a piantare almeno un albero in
effetti ne avevo piantato solo uno è la
mia esperienza da mago è impiegato in
banca non giocava certo a mio favore ma
oggi siamo nel 2020 e di alberi ne
abbiamo piantati 1.700.000 più di cinque
quanto al giorno la tecnologia
funzionava ma era difficile fare tutto
da soli così abbiamo pensato di
coinvolgere nc e cooperative di
contadini per piantare sempre più alberi
mettendo a loro disposizione i
finanziamenti e la tecnologia per vedere
quello che stavamo facendo
abbiamo iniziato a progettare dei
sistemi agroforestali coinvolgendo
direttamente le cooperative locali e
chiedendo loro quali alberi volevano
piantare per loro piantare solo alberi
forestali non aveva tutto questo valore
perché molti villaggi erano circondati
da foresta e per loro era una risorsa
molto abbondante mentre invece potevano
aver bisogno più di alberi da frutto che
erano difficile a volte da far crescere
avevano bisogno di più esperienza
tecnica e così abbiamo iniziato a
disegnare dei sistemi agroforestali che
potessero mischiare alberi forestali
alberi da frutto e anche delle colture
locali cercando di massimizzare
l'impatto in termini ambientali globali
sappiamo che ogni albero assorbe co2 ma
anche un impatto in termini ambientali
locali ovvero arrestare la
deforestazione bloccare la
deforestazione o cercare di arricchire i
suoli e aggiungendo un pezzo veramente
importante del nostro lavoro
gli alberi da frutto gli alberi da
frutto che portano enormi benefici
sociali perché i contadini sono
proprietari delle terre sono proprietari
degli alberi e sono proprietari dei
frutti che quindi riescono a garantire
la loro sicurezza alimentare e anche del
reddito extra derivante dalla vendita
dei frutti sul mercato locale
abbiamo quindi colmato il nostro gap
perché molti contadini nel sud del mondo
solitamente si dedicano all'agricoltura
perché possono raccogliere il 6 8 mesi i
frutti del loro lavoro e molte volte non
possono aspettare che un albero dia i
suoi frutti
dovrebbero asportare 45 anni
ed oggi quello che facciamo e colmare
questo gap ovvero finanziare i contadini
fino a che gli alberi non producano i
frutti da loro sperati poco a poco i
contadini hanno percepito il valore di
questi alberi e così a partire dai primi
oggi più di 100 mila contadini in 17
differenti paesi del mondo vengono
finanziati per piantare alberi
grazie a una comunità globale di utenti
che ha deciso di finanziarli e che può
vedere i frutti del loro lavoro
semplicemente online
dicono che per arrestare i cambiamenti
climatici
bisognerebbe piantare 20 miliardi di
alberi in dieci anni ne abbiamo di spazi
non dobbiamo andare a piantarli su marte
sarebbe un albero ogni tre anni
se ognuno di noi lo facesse ma quanto ci
vuole oggi a piantare un albero 23
secondi e pochi click
dicono che le cose più belle nascono
quasi sempre per gioco per passare il
tempo
o come diciamo noi la green the planet